all right and we are laughs and I get to
say my saying again why don't you stole
it from me last flash flash back we all
laugh the double-dip edition what's
going on
yeah I'm just at the time we're like
help we don't know if there's gonna be a
flash point we're both kinda tired
things that are going holy crap this is
the longest one ever we both kind of
thought that um it wouldn't be based on
you know the actual reveal stream this
week I mean they're just pumping out
information left and right and it's just
like yeah man hey shout out to a punch
good morning sir in the ILP Clint it's
good to see you first in the chat that's
what's up man
but yeah man this was definitely a
surprise you know and um it's just so
much good stuff to cover you know this
had me pumped that got me out of my
tired state and I was like yeah we got
to do it that way you completely was
with me we got a lot to get get into
yeah
so Bungie felt like dropping the longest
twelve ever dropped the video yesterday
had the reveal stream to date like well
two and a half days ago now probably
yeah what a couple times then since then
but not a lot we did our full breakdown
of the combat reveal stream before so
we're not gonna spend much time on that
great huh
but seriously just kind of a recap of
that are you feeling good about what's
coming
yeah I'm really I'm really feeling good
this is like I said each day I just get
more pumped and obviously you see the
other content creators putting out stuff
it's that Energy's in the air you know
and we're ready to try all this stuff
out and we're all in kind of like a prep
mode for forsaking so to speak you know
so like I said it just there's a lot of
good things to do now in preparation for
that and I'm like I'm definitely hype
man this is the most high height I've
been in the destin'd st2 cycle like
cycle right now so
oh good time good time what about you I
mean I'm the same because I mean we were
hype for destiny too for sure we thought
it was coming but I think
was questions i was probably even more
optimistic than I should have been with
something that was out there but
generally yeah I think this I'm feeling
confident ly excited I think is a better
way for everybody we've seen yeah I'm
actually feeling like I feel like I can
get excited because they keep should
they they have shown a whole bunch of
stuff which sometimes I'd be like hey I
don't want to see too much but they've
showed a lot of the things that I've we
were kind of finally looking for like
the time to kills the combat systems the
armor perks weapons things like that are
finally coming in to where we get some
views on those so it's the cautious
optimism is turning towards a a little
bit more unbridled optimism oh oh okay
[Music]
you always mo but it's good to hear that
even you kind of getting into that quiet
confidence excited you know any kind of
thing
yeah so I mean ammo like economy is
something I'm pretty sure they're just
gonna get constant feedback on hopefully
they can make some quick changes if it
needs it just because I mean having
three shotguns and there's like one
bullet in each and especially ammo drop
in and how that's gonna be in PvE versus
PvP and there's no way who's going on
there but again overall like I think
that feeling better now that if it's not
this if it's not Claire right they do
these monthly things more frequently now
that I'm seeing it happen absolutely
Emma
absolutely I said we're only concern us
keep this Cheney from you had a lot to
talk about um was just I like how you
just mentioned about I'm a little
worried about shotguns I got a lot of
you I'm like oh yeah you can't really
exist like that in PvP because you're
only gonna get two and you're gonna
deplete your ammo but I'm still thinking
in the skilled hand and the fact that
special ammo still drops from a kill cuz
like let's put case-in-point in
comparison if you're using a sniper and
in a cool loadout sense like in your
energy slot
if you get the kill the special box is
all the way over there right but as a
shotgun user you need to kill boom you
getting this special again you see I
said so I'm a little worried about that
that's the only I think your chance to
talk to you about and I'm a little
worried I'm like damn I hope we don't go
back to the felwinter's lie era remember
that oh yeah I mean that's a whole
different range on shotguns and watching
the shotguns used in the combat stream
they didn't feel quite as range heavy if
that makes sense like yeah it wasn't
rangefinder and shot package ins it
didn't feel like shotgun was an actual
sniper like Phil winters was yeah that's
games it's tough because that's where
Bungie like can't win I mean a shotgun
like I've like shot a few like I'm done
shooting like you know skeet or whatever
and that's like the thing is pretty far
away and somehow this like spread a
pellet still gets a pretty small target
and you're sitting there going like okay
so I know they're Guardians but I don't
have guardian little shotguns how much
damage do I do but they are still far
away even if it's short like even if
it's like a tight barrel shotgun it's
like you're still gonna do some damage
to mess somebody up pretty bad
absolutely but it's also like how do you
how do you balance Kingdom and it's like
from watching and stream like I think
are they still like you Walker in the
corner under shotgun you're gonna die
yeah I mean those are gonna be there so
you just came from player corners or use
that bow and see through walls you're
scared about shotguns oh yeah if all the
elite people get that bow in their hands
listen it trust me I mean it's one of
those things the only good thing I can
say though that they're doing this time
around supposedly ones that seems like
everything is getting a buff or some
left right like so hopefully there will
be things to count on and compete you
know also in that space and things you
can do so we'll see again I'm gonna
reserve judgment to be one of those
pulse rifles apparently they drop
everything about it was like we gotta
get our hands on it but it's looking it
looks good it looks fun I like the
variety it's gonna bring because I think
that was one of the things we were
talking
a little bit in between was the fact
that as a sniper you could hold down a
lane yes and you can't do that right now
because nobody has snipers but if you at
least even have a few bullets in there
you're a threat down the lane for at
least a second so I mean that changes
the way the the lanes play the way the
way things feel stuff like that so um
I'm excited
absolutely so let's get into what we got
alright so skipping over the combat
stream if you want to watch it we did
our overview they have there's generally
so first they talk about some weapons
that are actually going to be going out
of there energy or power slot and
they're gonna go into a kinetic slot
which is also should be by my
understanding the kinetic should be what
like ammo level one yeah right yeah
kinetic special so you've got the Bala
GAMP shotgun Shepards one sniper rifle
on orange gun
I don't know alone as a god yeah daddy's
deep grade sniper okay yeah Fermi
paradox shotgun pretty jackal in silicon
or ammo which I do have silicon neuroma
but yeah can I ask you what's that I
don't know what that that's the
pyramidion sniper okay okay nightfall
exclusive one said the icao sniper and
shotgun will be locked to solar and
there's a full list out there there's
actually on reddit guys I'll kind of try
and post that link in the description
online he's got into video so I know I'm
Lord's will have it as well it's a every
weapon yes up here every weapon somebody
data mined it now granted this is from
the API so if it's wrong there sorry but
right what this is gonna be is what
everything is gonna change to so me for
example the first thing I looked at and
I'm saying to use this as an example so
you've got Uriel's gift that is going to
be anytime you pull it from your year
one collection it's going to come out as
art and stay there right correct but the
big distinction they said is that if you
have a Uriel's gift now or two of them
for example
one of them Ark yes no wait one of them
solar make one of them void so you have
those two you have those locked in in
any other future ones you pull would be
arks you would have an optional option
of all three so if you still love your
eels gift mm-hmm of each type then lock
the ones that don't exist here in their
damage types before August 28th and and
then what at that point they're locked
in said okay yeah me my big one was the
man
let's go rifle yeah yeah it was funny I
just started using that maybe two weeks
ago so yeah that's it it's welcome to a
good PD PD awesome oh it's good I mean
it's actually better for me and PvE but
it's sadly I mean no PvE is worried yeah
yeah oh it's it's a faster nameless
midnight in my opinion cuz it's to one's
rpm and um yeah man acting it feels so
good it's snappy it's quick I love it
you got that explosive round damage I'm
loving it yeah so on that one I've got
it's gonna be void so I've got an arc
and a void so I need to turn one of mine
into solar so I've got the option for
all three and then I'm gonna be set
there so yeah so I mean there's a huge
list we'll have in the link so look for
that one guys if there's any certain
weapons that you've got something of and
you're like hey I always want to make
sure I have at least one copy of this as
arc and it's never going to be locking
in before laughs dope take a look at
that whole bunch of stuff up there
oh yeah before we get too far I'm gonna
switch over to tab - it's gonna watch we
gonna do this together we have why is it
but you guys get to join us for it so
it's never the viewing pleasure
hashtag spoiler warning dreaming city
but this is at least the way the
dreaming city like yeah we see some
stuff but it's a better trailer where
there's less boilers I think so
here we go let's go Petra Alex nice of
Easter's know oh yeah there's still like
some Lord of the Rings type Johnny going
on right here
got some hive hmm puzzles it's looks so
cool shelter I did the our team deeper
to the ruins it's got a hundred getting
busy Lucia hopefully that I look like
Lord of wolves I hope that's a lot of
walls now I know every lab mister that's
my big this one we see before the blind
well when this doesn't like a
coordination protocol type yeah it
almost got that feel there's a trace
rifle yes but it's like one big circle
that look people are sleeping on that
are super for hunting man comes a night
with the oak in the city of LinkedIn law
for the fearless that looks so DT
artwork man oh dude yeah this we hiked
that just going through that door right
that like that is a that rain is gonna
be serious this is type of stuff my boy
adequate anything in this by the way
oh yes that's it it's fantastic like I
said the morphine oh yeah I'm ready yep
so jump on that gets pre-order bonus
[Music]
yeah since the ornament is actually the
smoking effect I think which is pretty
cool doh so things in there not much you
know nothing major just
I never amazing insanity yes so one of
the big ones in there is the blind well
which looks to be prison of elders
crossed with escalation protocol because
it's gonna be probably more in the game
cuz it's on the dreaming city and it's
one big circle of doom it looks like
yeah it looks it's gonna be intense man
and without give enough I think we don't
get for second enough credit with all
these only to introducing you see right
oh we got another mole we got gambit you
know you guys got a lot of things to do
you know and we've already heard that
there's gonna be tons of Secrets there
and we're gonna find out what's going on
and hopefully you know still protagonist
so today I'm saying what's going on or
anything
and that's Petra I don't know I mean the
the the the running thing on the streets
right now is that Sabbath duel is may be
controlling things behind the scene but
the fear is um that I guess the fear
from the destiny lore guys is that they
don't do what they did in Worman which
is kind of rush so everybody felt that
it was kind of you know I mean so that's
that's the thing so I I feel my money's
on we'll see what happened to the Queen
I'm just gonna guess to me maybe she's
behind maybe her fate
my guess is maybe her fate is why
Aldrich is acting crazy that's what I'm
going with and ultimately maybe Savage
is behind the scene so I'm running with
this theory right now we see if I'm I'm
right when you know we finally get to I
mean yeah there's too many things out
there between the plain card that has
the Queen on it it was like collectors
packs yeah one crazy yeah
Queens like tetchy owns those little
guards who made the thing that attacked
mm-hmm cannot remember the taking King's
name orcs orcs when they attacked his
ship those three but kind of melded with
her one of those literally like the
shadow thing you're attacking in the
mission pieces so she's if like if
they're there or if some of those are
around them she's somewhere in
midst of all of this or at least should
be don't yeah yeah man it's just so much
mystery of like who's wise anjing doing
this you didn't mean like so again we
don't find that like I said I just
hopefully they pace it right they set it
up right it looks like they doing the
right thing with setting it up into the
raid
you know saying all of that that's cues
from taking King you know let us just do
it right that's all out all I was you
know just yeah let's see how they go
with that but it looks like looks good I
love everything I'm seeing from
extremist ideon like I said i'ma an
awoken fanboy so it's all for me all
this is me so wide awake and dreaming
yeah watch that trailer a couple times
over posit where you need to but yeah
Lord of the Rings the the elf city
that's exactly the feels I'm getting and
like I said we cannot commend like I
said the art team the marketing team
mangled
I'm never dies knock it out the park
every time say what you want about this
a you could be a destiny hater but you
look at it you if you're the hardcore
does it mean look at it a second you
can't say that you're not tempted
you got kids what about my boys out to
Lordaeron jacks he said the same thing
said dat like there's a party there's
like I might want to try it but I'm not
gonna we're gonna put their money down
there got me before you resume their
cattle I catch themselves yeah like I'm
totally up what exactly what as
continues well yeah so after you guys
watch that trail and journal about what
is to come I just like that there's the
upside down I can't wait to see that
alright so all of the topics some of
these are small but our little tangents
on some of these may be crazy so I had
something advanced we're gonna dive in
sort of how to become legend in year 2
so weapon tuning and systems aren't the
only thing changing the investment team
talks about like acquiring power or what
you're gonna be doing different
activities so we're gonna try and not
read this verbatim there may be certain
things that we need to clarify and we'll
check them yes
but the main things I do want to read
this one because it's what they wanted
to accomplish with the progression their
high level goals and the economy in
season four you want to bring back the
days when you are impressed when you see
someone at max power level in the time
thank you
thank you I've been saying this for a
while yeah I've been I've been watching
the flashpoint I like that
beautifully though but like max power
should be earned should not be handed
out in public events preach and the fact
that they're showing but what the
intention is based on I love how they're
talking what I love about this rob is I
love how they were explaining the
mindset for a decision right so again
that's what made me fall in love with SD
I went to the tower
holy where did you get that from how did
that person you know I'm saying and then
it's like oh wow that he did trial okay
cool oh wow he has to rage Wow you know
I mean like that's destiny that's
essence stuff great well yeah ii want
the experience of leveling and then
powering up should be meaningful yes
like for me this is a big one because as
you level up sometimes it was
frustrating yeah to either get something
that's below your level or the stupid
thing of you know mobs which they're
taking out those aren't gonna give you
$5.00 anymore when you work on those
it's not gonna be oh by the way you're
getting something to power levels below
you but you're really above but it's
your power level and it's it just
psychologically never felt good so it's
just like this kind of sacks and that's
hopefully gonna change or three players
should have a sense of discovery when
earning awards from different activities
now this is kind of a vague sentence
yeah I guess it's more like as you do
different activities you'll be getting
different things you should actually
like feel like you're getting something
new in different places only though yeah
and the vibe I got I don't know if they
over my supporting later mix-a-lot job
is that they don't intend on showing you
everything from no I like how it's been
so far so I also wanted yeah do that so
there's a couple of something difficult
the rewards should be special or unique
thank god I know this is kind of a dull
moment but yes
yes he is looking for you
wonderful Vanguard 1 and it's he's
looking at you it's like you do a night
phone you look up here's your garbage
exactly yeah I think not all the best
sources of power in a week should be
apparent on the director so that's where
you're talking about it as well so
you're gonna have some of your things
that you're going to do that are moving
places you're gonna have some stuff that
is just unknown some stuff is gonna be
puzzles of mysteries you find so there's
a lot more to do this is actually gonna
be I think a viable option to level up
yeah absolutely absolutely which is
great mm-hmm so acquisition of power
this is kind of a big one yeah basically
I said in year 1 they could the the
wards would drop at whatever power level
you were close to things like that they
wanted the power level to actually
matter which is probably one of the
biggest things yet is they want power to
matter you shouldn't be able to go into
a raid and be pulled through when you're
like you know 60 levels under level 4
eater of worlds just as you said you did
with a couple of your friends mm-hmm
like be like oh I'm totally under level
and you're like you'll be fine yes yeah
yeah absolutely
so when players earned powerful rewards
these items should never scale down to
where they don't give an increase in
power thank you thank you
English that's that's just the proper
feeling behind it if I do something
difficult as I said I should get
something that's at least gonna help me
improve that's the whole point of
accomplishing something tough right yeah
that's a reward that is much needed much
needed and this is a nice clarification
even if you're a hundred power levels
over an activity you're going to help a
buddy and doesn't mean it shouldn't
grant you at least something you know
yeah one power level above do something
and what that does is it encourages sure
purring now because a lot of the high
powered guy is not really the what he's
literally just doing this out of his art
for you so let him get something let him
get a little something you know
even if it's a little thing that that
also promotes the Sherpa culture helping
people in Ukraine that kind of stuff and
um well needed change love well we don't
go so far for power now so there are new
sources of power for powerful gears
there's different like reset timings and
things like that so there's going to be
a more there's gonna be more frequency
in the times that you can get powerful
gear more variety of things to do all
good things cannot argue that one enough
yes
milestones are changing actually which
is kind of go ahead so for one so you
guys can see the map we've got the
bottom you've got the vanguard gambit
and crucible we'll get to some more
details on those in a little bit left
side you in left side and top you got
the old planets the usual stuff and on
the right mm-hmm
sure in the Dreaming city I love how
everything also else looks like you know
this little circular planet everything
on the rights like this like just like
almost emptiness yeah nothing is there
just like click on it to damage now on
our Twitter anyways like don't worry
it's our necess yeah so yeah they're
just kind of consolidated a little bit
yeah your old raids will be connected to
necessary cuz hopefully we've done what
we need to do on the ship we cleaned up
the trash the guy and then you know in
the Scout towers factory we've done all
of calluses beating just chillin I don't
there's weird to know if you dizzy just
still children in the system I don't
know that's kind of that's that whole
feeling of your one kind of encompassed
right there just effect when they
strapped him to necess and you got to go
in there to see it it's like yeah yeah
that's kind of a disjointed disconnected
weird things like this literally looks
like it fits now like you got the
tangled Shore and everything just flows
and connects you know simplified UI and
and at the end of the day we don't have
to experience even though like I said
Leviathan wasn't terrible raid you know
I'm saying it's just that it was just
disjointed from a story from a narrative
perspective so
this is I'm glad we're going away from
that throw that babbling on this and
let's move on exact so the milestone try
it's always your thing up to the left
it's been revamped basically they're
taking out the repetitive stuff from
there you're obvious things like your
flashpoint on your place of the week
your crucible things your you know
nightfall strikes those those are gonna
be actually tied to their little planets
or coordinates or things like that so
it's not just gonna you're not gonna
have this list of like here's your six
milestones once you're done with this
list for the week you're done mm-hmm the
feel behind it to say like you know Kate
your next like important piece is gonna
be stuck in a milestone because that's
how your progression is going to be but
not all things are gonna be listed in
there as they said so like a game but
has a flashpoint thing for the next
three days and you go down there to game
but then it's got the details or you go
to Vanguard and you see you've got like
a nightfall still to do and then your
powerful gear and there as well so each
thing is gonna be tied to it's either
planet director bubble as opposed to
just open my milestones tab and when
it's empty I'm done for the week yeah
different feeling different fit I like
that it makes you it makes the world it
might be in feel more like you know when
you see them on different locations okay
I have to go there that kind of stuff
you know the love trigger you know I
wasn't I didn't hate it but it's just
felt weird no no coming from do you one
so this is I thought this was a nice
change yeah so they said many other
milestones like turn them into quote
activity challenges that's just in your
pursuits tab so now when you go to
inventory that things at the top you'll
be looking at it looking in there all
the time same things you do your quests
for you know sleeper or anything like
that it's in that same section so all of
those are just gonna be tucked in there
for either bounties are also gonna be in
there so all those pieces connected
you'll be using that a lot which is
probably why they put it at the top yep
so I do like the director looks good I
was like to see these images between
years I was kind of fun because I like
to see how things evolve when they took
earth and they added the whole you know
plague to zone or whatever I think it
was played yeah oh you get a plague
Lance
so we added that to earth and they
completely like modified that map to
give it the other size so yeah I was
enjoying our changes because that's like
those are some of the biggest evolutions
it's like yeah they threw the radon
there it's like or this Saturday but
this is like this is the big shift this
is things change where's my space
burrito dissolute Lee crucible also be
changes so see you now you see how when
you go into the crucible tab for example
quick play weekly you know challenge
five matches complete you know full gear
though actually changing it from because
last what was it I think all of your
one's been kills through shacks so now
just five matches complete that's just
I'll for those who don't love crucible
and it's their yeah five matches
complete whether you love it or hate it
it gets people to dabble in get some
people in the playlist once a week or
actually it might be every four days if
this is one of those things that rotates
but yeah I believe it does a little take
quicker to flash points they did say
they will not be just tied to you don't
the Tuesday reset it's gonna be a
four-day thing so and it looks like the
little yellow icon here is attached to
your weekly playlist mm-hmm Rumble over
here I can kind of barely see it on it
and then also over here on the
competitive yeah all the different
options besides private matches are
gonna be a way for you to do it so
however you want to play him you can get
back those out so yeah that's cool
that's probably gonna be a similar thing
so you look up here on strikes you've
got one is gonna be this little
challenge you'd probably have I'm
guessing a nightfall you get a challenge
on earth you get a challenge on IO which
is odd that there's one on two planets
mm-hmm and it's gonna have one general
looking rundown I'd guess that's
probably your main weekly ones I mean
give it so absolutely so activities
changing a little more details so
strength changing come honest we ate the
whole bunch of stuff is changing so get
ready yeah we got a lot here a lot he
I'm very curious on your feelings once
you go through this is a bag right here
X is your bag so heroic strikes are
truly being retired
they're just going away rest in peace
now honestly I'm okay with that because
heroics and bank guards are just kind of
a waste of two lists yeah there's no
reason to have both it should be strikes
or something that like the nightfall is
its own thing
strikes heroic strikes I never touched
Vanguard they were just there for
uselessness so it literally took up
space bo z battle forsaken players are
gonna have three different difficulties
to pick from what's up addict are you
doing 300 level 400 level 500 level yeah
but then the next line is once you're 40
power over a given playlist it won't
appear as an option for you to select
collect like if you're 40 power level
over in your next playlist is 40 but
what if I'm 350 I'm 50 below the 400
strike list does that mean I gotta go
grind before I go do strikes yes good
question um no I think like I said if
you're 40 over together so if that means
if we start it's 300 you're 340 the 300
goes away and then the 400 opens up so
your question is what if you want to do
what if I'm 350 what do I play 400 power
400 power play this okay what if I'm 349
and everything 50 levels above these
immune I doubt it but I'm gonna see how
to handle I can't if they're gonna if
they make a foot if they're gonna make
you 40 power over eliminating a strike
strike playlist that you can't access
doesn't you've got to be able to still
do it it's pretty harder yeah but you
still got to be able to do it or is that
kind of incentive to just go do other
stuff maybe maybe you may be right you
may be right I mean in labor I can't see
that you think they got put question
marks over the bosses I mean that's the
thing that they're whole one of the big
things they played is when they change
the whole powered differentiation
between you and an enemy yeah yeah so
that's why when you are 270 and if you
want to go to a heroic strike they were
straight-up immune like right now when
we're doing
former I was like I need to go through
strikes it was like all the modifiers
not so bad at least that can help me if
I'm working on some stuff right I could
not touch anything
it was literally straight-up immune like
I shot it nothing happened and that was
like 60 power levels and they said it
was it's now a 50 power level
distinction that's why I figure 40 over
so if I'm 345 I'm 40 over the 300 but I
can't have 400 is gonna whup my butt
yeah you may be right Dave this may be
their way of saying hey you're not ready
go do other things and maybe this is
their way of escalation protocol in the
strikes right cuz men when we first
started escalation protocol we first got
one mind oh yeah Rawls is running wild
out here like it's like that's how
really was so yeah you know what you may
be right this could be their way of
getting it you know I'm saying do other
stuff slowly gets power up and then
coming yeah it's like I'm gonna start
cuz I'm probably not gonna get a
prestige rate in but I'm probably gonna
start it like 394 at least on my Titan
396 somewhere in there yeah so I mean
I'll be close to 400 so I can at least
play those but it's nice as you do the
same thing from 400 500 is gonna happen
all over again now some of that level
he's gonna happen during the story
there's gonna be quite a bit of in-game
leveling as well so see how the
progression goes but that's kind of an
interesting thing to say 400 and 500
especially is going to be probably the
biggest time we're like 441 I'm here is
what happens to see where absolutely and
honestly I think the thought process is
just to kana I don't say time game but
they kind of want you not to be able to
please do that content I think they're
trying to stop people from the overall
theme since a lot of these updates if
you notice is to stop people from trying
to power level crazy fast if you notice
that I'm not people will still find a
way but I do yeah but I mean they're
still gonna be like okay so I can't go
do strikes right now I gotta find
something different which is good right
that's what I think it is I think that's
exactly what's going on
okay so once you're 40 so the 500
parallel playlists will always be there
500 stays touch that if you can just
always have modifiers mm-hmm like I mean
patrols are pretty general strikes again
have something going on so legacy
players if you don't get forsaken there
gonna be 200 play lists
you'll be match made in two year one
strikes and they will still have
modifiers as well
mm-hmm and all modifiers will go away
between the 28th and the 4th right that
is correct now try not to scroll too far
the nightfall got up to our godly
brother-in-law R dove solo beast mastery
the the esoteric one himself yes yes and
so this and be like man I get a lot of
stuff to do because when it comes to the
nightfall there are going to be for one
the prestige is being retired so scoring
I think will be in the normal nightfall
which is but there's gonna be three
nightfall strikes to choose from yes I
like this yeah you mentioned something
specific what was your thoughts on it
why this is you deal because I'm gonna
be completely full transparency I didn't
really care for the press ds9 for
Saturday just so I really I would think
that did like a leave me to it rhythm it
was just a little too confusing and
convoluted on how to get it when I first
started now just like an and then like I
would just do the reckon I forget my
powerful role and leave now you know I'm
not I'm glad you know people that did
like hey more power to them but I think
they needed to consolidate and I'm
saying and just make it easier then now
with these three nightfall strikes I can
now actually farm DFA you never saying
like I can farm stuff and that's what I
want to do because it's like drop rates
are already small and you know like if
they're gonna continue that trend of
tying a rare weapon you know loop
specific you know rewards I mean you
know strike with specific excuse me you
know this this is cool I like that I
actually like there so I'm more for it
the prestige thing in theory sounded
cool I just didn't like the
implementation the vibe I felt was have
people really you know didn't know what
they were doing with it anyway so hey
you know I'm good on it there's any
person what
yeah no I mean I like the three is cool
because it gives you options that way
you're not stuck grinding one yeah but I
mean as you go through if you switch up
what you're working on per week if
there's like a good rotation of here's a
year one all I never did actually get
you know DFA still don't have that some
the new stuff there's one stuck from the
middle all those three kind of rotating
through gives you a chance to not be
like or on the other hand if it's a
strike you hate your kind of like
screwed yeah like if you're a solo
player and you're like hey I know I can
do this one these two are somewhat of a
challenge for me but this one at least I
can do I can grind out my solo gear if I
find some buddies maybe we'll do the
others for fun too but it's a way for
you to have an option and I think
options are good while still I think
options of challenging difficult
challenging ly difficult activities is a
good thing never like just more stuff to
do sure mm-hmm
absolutely absolutely so that one seems
cool the oh let me can I get this one
that coming up medical students down
let's go down a little bit I skip
because I wanted yeah yeah you can take
the meditation heroic adventures that's
all kind of tied together yeah
meditations retired and replaced with
the heroic story playlist thank God
meditations I could not stand I did not
like the rewards associated with them so
that I'm happy about that and heroic
story playlist I like that because that
is now shades of solstice that felt
exciting and I get to play you know some
kind of cool you wanna you know and say
I wanna get into that so they said then
we got new campaign missions will be
featured at a 500 power while old
campaign missions will be set to a power
level relative to their release this is
shows legacy players will still enjoy
story activities at their leisure didn't
her Icarus research tokens will no not
well no longer be used as currency will
be removed from inventories the
legendary parade do you help me I don't
that's this that special sake that's
just her said yeah that's all what do
you want so if you want to get it before
August 28th and then heroic adventures
are being added to all destinations so
that's interesting when the destination
is point
one event will be selected to be her
walk per day with the exceptions of
mercury and Mars do you feel about that
uh uh what for heroic adventures yeah
and then you got the whole the two
destinations will function as they
currently do but they will gain an
additional adventure per day that's I
guess mercury and Mars when they just
work if you go to the character and it's
gonna be like the if you go to an tabret
right now she's got her adventures to
select already right so just having I
mean I think they work fine mostly so
coming to you too
so overall between the meditations that
you know the way they handed their
research reputation and these adventures
like well yet with that yeah meditations
I never found either I'm with you
heroic story playlist was always fun if
they have a lot like one single modify
in there just to mix it up a little bit
whether it's easy hard something like
that that might rotate everyday just all
that stuff is always a way to have some
variety give you a challenge give you
something else to click on to go do yeah
I mean meditations were annoying because
if I there was something I wanted to
play I could not specifically choose it
I want them to put the story missions
back on the map as part of reason
they're there you just want to go play
when you're gonna go run a buddy through
one you want to go look people couldn't
go explore as easily these people who go
hunting and searching every nook and
cranny and to probably wait for like of
meditation yeah they probably would
still do it that way but it's annoying
to be like I just wanna go play this
mission just because it looked long yeah
almighty a mighty return town let me go
cute this thing up real quick hey give
me two minutes
hey this looks kind of amazing I'm on
this thing leg mmm yeah and ultimately
do another thing for me I said as the
Osiris fanboy as much as the DLC as a
whole you know was underwhelming you
know I would like to replace some of the
missions so I could see the cinematics
in interaction because we didn't see
them a lot right as it is so yeah so
having it in other content you don't get
to see those cinematics no more so I
would like to be able to really do that
you know saying that's one thing and I
said to myself I'm not playing the
campaign it was an but
you know me so that's really really
where I'm at with it yeah I mean I just
like the just a more choice of selection
heroic adventures being added which are
gonna give you something else to do that
day they're gonna I just like and all of
those things hopefully adventures are
all they want people to get back into
adventurous because some of them are
cool they wanted to give you a better
reason
we'll see if things change like lost
sectors if they give me love so there's
I think gonna be some good things about
this definitely I don't see anything
negative here for sure yet I mean all
the stuff seems positive for me so far
absolutely all right before you get so
economy updates activity modifiers will
be shared across Oro adventures throwing
story missions and strikes so that's
actually kind of nice yeah if it's gonna
be a void cinch and it's gonna be
Grenadier and glass or something like
that you know kind of what suspect
forward that day right so it's just it's
kind of unique you and so this'll be one
weekly singe daily buff and a daily
debuff that will be there just across
the board they did say thank goodness
because I'm really tired of it not
mattering brawler and grenadier
modifiers will have their chart recharge
times adjusted to ensure they're
noticeable yeah cuz Grenadier doesn't
even feel powerful right now it feels
like I mean it was before that's when
you talk about the nothing manacle
audience love that video as one of my
favorites you do love you would get
create energy from using your grenade
and it was really fast [ __ ] charge
time I get almost probably never I mean
that was a point where esoteric did his
probably like no guns he would kill
every single thing with a grenade but
that's like that's the variety that
helps it be fun there's my brother
playing months around the world shout
out to breakout shout out popping up on
my screen there but that's exactly what
they're like you know so if brawler and
you have the throwing knife is the
hunter or now the throwing hammer as a
Titan which is fun if those are gonna be
something that's you know chunk it it
hits really hard you pick it back up and
you can just run around and peck
everybody with like the new hammer
that's gonna be really fun cuz you have
to pick it up within six seconds
but if you pick it up it's recharged so
if they have brawler actually be proper
and that'll be that'll just be fun to do
he's about that was there was a reason
to play that way and that's when it came
to the scoring of like okay so extra
points from grenade kills or extra
points from melee kills or super kills
those are the other pieces that help the
scoring in d1 yes like make you play a
different way and they haven't done that
yet and then yeah I missed that old
scoring system how they used to have you
know and you see the different things
you get the rainbow perk you know say
like you get all these different based
on how you played that scoring you know
rewarded you based on that and it was a
really cool thing like they added and
then I got a hold that someone comes
back you know cuz I really liked it yeah
yeah I mean it didn't take away from
anything but it did wanted a different
challenge or you were going for points
it truly would like if it was melee
especially like it was a completely
different play style than granite here
and then super kills absolutely I would
leave juju every week I mean a big
change made me pull different weapons
out use I mean when it was melee Monte
Carlo Solly yeah you had all the
specific items that would steer towards
things your classic things and if you
ate one work on score you don't have to
but if you do yeah it made me like you
say you said it perfectly made you
change that line I remember that I used
to do like that whole thing when I would
you know Monte Carlo out for my warlock
I would have a clause of Amon Cara and
he's all day you know say it's like a
complete male name it made you make
specific builds so certain exotics had
value so hopefully you know I know they
got a lot on their plate that make a lot
of changes but I hopefully at some point
you know season five maybe you know we
start getting some of that stuff back
cuz that part was cool indeed so
speaking of changes economy updates well
I said a lot of people play errs asking
about currencies and items that will or
won't be valuable this is one of the
biggest things is they're talking about
destination tokens in a rare destination
so if you got like just light or the
upgraded version of
both the tokens from that destination
will no longer be dropping you're not
gonna lose the ones you have you'll be
able to turn those in for reputation but
you won't get any more right on my 28th
also the destination materials that are
rare the blue ones will no longer drop
everything on a destination will be done
through their base material be it dusk
light shards or whatever the new thing
is on Mars that I can't pronounce
[Music]
but the first bullet point but they talk
about here is probably the one that
we're like huh they will need a main
source of reputation sorry it's number
two yeah
destination materials we part of the
cost to infuse different weapons and
armor across your arsenal I'm willing to
reserve judgment until it's implemented
but I just have again I'm not trying to
fear monger but all I can do one fear
I'm remembering oh you gotta get 50
spend middle I don't want to be doing
that again it's an interesting design
choice why are we tying infusion into
materials you know I mean I like tokens
go away but we got I got a see I gotta
see how that plays man the only thing I
can think of is you know they want you
to stay invested to that location you
know I mean but I got I don't so I got
to see the enthuse this is an
interesting design choice and I'm very
curious to hear that I wish we had the
thought process behind that but yeah
they can explain to me why do we have
why is materials from the destination
needed to infuse gear like that is weird
to me I'm trying to get my wrap my mind
around it so I don't know that's just
where I'm I'm trying to be I'm cautious
about that one I don't know believe me
people who and spin metal farming
arounds and stuff like that I'm hoping
they're not just like you know blind I'd
to what happened in the past I know they
know
but it's still odd very so I'm with you
I'm like as you said it's the currency
if it's like hey you got to go you know
it should be one and if you're gonna get
those you're gonna get the dissolution
material here let's kind of clarify some
of this your one challenges that granted
reputation tokens are being retired
well we replaced by bounties offered on
each destination that provide
destination materials I know you'll have
things to do to get those materials
right if bounties are on a daily
rotation engine up wait too long so
depending on your currency they did say
infusion is going to be more expensive
yeah and again I just shout out to my
boy Lord zero leucon we had a chat going
and um you know I just
we want the grind don't get me wrong but
we don't I don't want force crime
because like you know I know what I'm
not gonna you know we'll get to faction
rallies later but there were things the
community did not like about that event
right and I don't want extended grind
that's not fun you know I'm saying so
again god I gotta see it too you know I
just I don't want it to be a game we all
everybody's got that ghost looking for
dust like shards on e DS like I don't
want it to be the whole day I'm
searching you know for these things now
granted there are bounties I get it you
know I'm saying so we'll see how it
plays we'll see what the rates of
infusion are but I'm a little concerned
yeah so it says anything that previously
granted destination tokens or rare
materials will reward common so you got
public events
you got bounties you've got patrols
you've got chests all of those things on
top of the things that you're gonna see
on the ground are still gonna record
those mints you know get those materials
so I mean I haven't used some own
materials in a while and I have like 500
of each of the tokens so I mean I'm
probably doing okay just the fact that I
haven't turned in like phase glass
kneels I have 48 of those yeah you know
sixteen dust it's just random crap is
sitting out there but I have so many
more tokens being the frequency that you
get tokens I think we're probably gonna
be okay it would be one of those things
as you said to slow down the beginning
so people aren't like Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam okay I got like level 20 on
this kind of getting done right
absolutely no I agree I agree
Lucy Lucy like I said I'm willing to
give them the benefit of doubt and see
it in action
maybe the influence rates or not it's
crazy you know I'm saying so you know
see Lucy she's got my antennas up oh
yeah
yes well yeah so the gunsmith will be
updated in season four not a big one but
instead of being 40 gunsmith materials
it's a hundred gunsmith materials for a
level he's also gonna be one of those
who probably provides new weapons and
people are really gonna dump all the
3,000 gunsmith materials or 10,000 or
whatever you got into him yes
so that's why yeah absolutely it lets me
out just a ton of people including
yourself that have so much guns with
material that they probably don't divide
I'm getting from numbers they're trying
to stop people on day one of an
expansion releasing power leveling yeah
right they did they stopped it with the
exotic on arm tournaments when people
just me with the UM engrams in here just
held on and then as soon as released
cash in cash and cash in you know and
the light will go up crazy fast same
thing with certain different currencies
I think this is more of that investment
because we know what what it's rumored
that the guns will have more of a
responsibility you know what's going on
in the future so yeah that's what that's
what I think's going on here yeah
speaking of him the arms likes arm sweet
stuff never came to pass data leaks
aren't always right so other tokens for
like iron banner Vanguard crucible
earned in season 3 may be redeemed at
their vendors in season 4 and now the
line and now the one that you got to
talk about trials of the nine will be on
hiatus during season four Wow the rest
of its just kind of whatever the nine is
on it's just off wow wow wow oh yeah
this hit me hard we knew they were
thinking about reworking it we knew that
um you know trials not in a good place
let's just call it what it is you know
season I mean D two trials
you know listen I'm all for the fourth
player in theory I just didn't feel it
work right I didn't feel you know
countdown was okay but it just was like
you know what sometimes I just want good
old elimination it was just something
about dream an elimination that felt
good right so as a trials player you
know very average tip but you know to me
it just felt good you know they were
trying to get the resins in a better
place they made some changes that helped
on that you know it's just I don't know
if there's a combination that a matter
you know just being such a team shot
matter with the maps it just never hit a
stride and you know how I feel about the
whole lore aspect trend don't get me
started
that is a little bit floating planet
people with the one sock and like I'm
sorry like I was never feeling it like
you why was my why narrative Lee is my
man not running trials and I just don't
understand and then if you're gonna go
this whole new weird space horror
direction with this chick and then and
we haven't learned anything even when
you beat people I've seen people go to
lighthouse you don't learn anything
about what's going on at least with
Osiris there was a whole thing he's
prepping guardians for a greater you
know I'm saying you had a vendor that
actually talk to you I don't liked it
judgment they get this check out it I'm
sorry I don't like her he like it's just
like it just feels like some spacey
trippy stuff that doesn't have anything
to do with destiny lore she don't like
my man Kings throw her in the bushes
Frederick's trash get this out of here
come back the early one my man's DLC
this is how you save the day budget take
it from kognito you have Osiris come
back for this and you're saying he he's
prepping you for the space Doritos
you're not strong enough
bring back the Egyptian gear cuz
everybody must admit that Egyptian girl
was snazzy
it was fly he was looking like I'm oorah
and it's in it in the tower you look at
you looking like you know or it was just
fresh man everything
I'll just go back to that there's no
reason this thing nobody likes it the
numbers show it you know and um also
let's not get into the cheating and all
that but again enough of my rant with
that my main thing is it didn't need a
revamp
I am shocked that they actually looks
like they're gonna do something major
it's gonna suck not to have it for a
season but I think ultimate is my
ultimate point on it I think they can
get away with it right now
so much to do right huh just one season
right number two December 3 months even
though that's me without it look it'll
feel you're gonna miss it you like oh
how I came back let's see what they did
but it's gotta be they've gotta really
go hard and early when I come early
because if they don't people like wait
trash you know people gonna win so you
know my thing is take the town get it
right you know and just and let's see
what happens let's see what happens but
um I was surprised the only thing now
for the PvP my PvP guys they're gonna be
in glory they gonna be in glory heavy
and the rumor is shots money follow-on
there's gonna be a new meta weapon kind
of how like regex was this one there's a
new I think it's a hand cannon something
weird name I don't know I don't know I I
see a shine up the fall I see him
talking people say imitating plane but
competitive don't get mad at me I gotta
get this virus wound that was the rumor
that that may be tied to it as an
evolving thing but from what I got so
far
okay so many my speculation can be wrong
but um but at the end of the day you
know Reggie is being retired anyway so
that's why most likely so um you know
we'll see what they do but that's my
much rouse bran
you know I am gonna it's sad to see it
go for that length of time
but if they're gonna rework it and
really do what they what community wants
I'm all for it yeah I'm in pretty think
you covered everything sorry
no I mean no no seriously it's like if
it's going away not a lot of people like
it me I've never been a huge trials
person anyway just because that level of
competitive PvP is not my strong suit
I've got some good people with me
stressful it's I'm it was always me
getting some randoms trying to get some
wins or if it's just like for me it's
never been a big thing but I know
generally people hate it so if it's
going away and getting a revamp I think
people are gonna be ok with it and I
hope they understand like they need some
time mm-hmm absolutely
yeah interesting interesting stuff that
one sentence definitely hit me up so we
got it slip BAM what's like the floor is
on fire actually yeah iron banner comes
back as you guys can see the iron fire
pits will price place the usual control
flags these are gonna be your control
points on maps which is I like it I mean
it's just a cool way to stand apart the
control points look cool you're running
over to the fire probably don't stand
too close to it it's just how you gonna
handle it because it's like as wedding a
dorm play with some places I'm gonna get
confused without you like I want to see
how this power play rule comes out
because if you capture all three zones
it locks them down for 20 seconds and in
the end of the power play all zones
reset mmmm' 20 second boost cuz normally
be like oh you got all three zones and
then someone's sitting there capping the
other one yeah and you lose it like two
seconds later but this time it's like if
you get all three zones oh you got 20
seconds to take advantage and I like
that that's alright but I also like the
fact they do a full reset it's not like
you hold it they have to deal like oh
well you just hold these two it's like
no everybody's gonna kind of do
something against exactly it's just not
gonna be completely one-sided to the
dominating team after that goes up there
was a chance to try to get back in the
mix but oh that yeah that's next week
control check out the enjoyment if you
need some you know careers well delay
times if you're going to mix it up a
little trial run before they throw this
into next year so this is their little
test phase to see how the power play
rule goes mm-hmm speaking of power
starting a season for iron banner we'll
have power advantages enabled
this is gonna set apart even more Case
Files won't be there yes so this is
really gonna be its own playlist of
power matters because trials won't even
have it when it comes back they say it
will wait now iron matters gonna be the
only thing and with power mattering you
didn't get forsaken I mean I just I
don't know why and I feel like it didn't
matter but somehow iron banner always
had a little bit of a different feel yes
and I could never quite figure out like
did my 320 power ever actually matter
was it completely useless getting up to
that next little level up there it's
like that's a little more incentive to
play to the top end as well because I
mean iron man will probably take a
little while to come out by the way
small tangent please Bungie if you ever
hear this if anybody listens to our
podcast from Bungie yes please don't
release the rain in three days yeah my
god way too much stuff to do and you
know most likely gonna do it hopefully
they hopefully they give it they give it
like when it comes out that week
hopefully they give it the next right at
least a week a week hopefully I'd say
I'd I'd love to ask two weeks is what I
would love to do because you'd get like
a couple resets in there you've got
people that are gonna go through the
story you've got the Dreaming city I
don't know what level it's gonna be at
for the regular how they're gonna handle
the rain difficulties but don't make it
so easily like just blow through the
story do a few things then people can
figure it out that's the final piece
yeah save it save that stuff like let
people level up let people grind out let
people start getting closer and then
release that stuff at like 550 and 600
mm-hmm at you know 500 like 475 and 550
like make it the top in please don't do
that
sorry tangent over no no I love it
I love it because you're right you know
um
I feel sorry you know you guys you know
you you make great content you know and
you know shout to everybody all the
podcasters I'm saying if I've seen Chad
oh my god
it's just like I feel bad I'm like you
literally have to no life it just so you
could be kinda rate ready ready because
of your light level you know and with
this the way light level is going right
there make it a power grind so you know
hopefully we got a lot to do as it is
story-wise a whole bit you know let it
be the following Friday you know I mean
the although chance you know I'm saying
to get the light level and then then go
for it but we'll see you Lucy I be
handling they tend to rush these things
but we'll still see I know so but yeah
at that point honestly for this one I
will straight up say I want to do it
clean fresh I'm gonna try and avoid the
spoilers on this one because it looks
too cool so moving down we got some
other stuffs faction farewell you know
that um you know they tried the renowned
mechanic which I liked you know the
factual ality then they said they got
great feedback
you know shouted s llegará he went in on
this ha oh my god did yeah he went in on
factory rallies like nobody completed so
basically you know the two main points
of feedback that were expressed was they
don't want to feel forced to participate
in every instance of the event each
season that I agree with you know I
literally when it started I was at e3
and I'm like damn so now when I come
back I only got two weeks and I got to
make a choice on three catalysts so for
me you know it was um crap graviton of
course I had to get that sucker for
graviton and as much as the faction the
fusion work all should have been my
second decision based on what they had I
was kind of loyal to high my faction new
monarchy and just went for theirs and I
like the colors of shape
you know yes I was a tough one you know
I'm saying and then the second thing
make the event progression I let a bit
less hardcore and more engaging so I'm
gonna let you grab that point as far as
the community feedback so making the
event progression one yeah like what
what DS is don't know the two things
that the community expressed about the
issues with the faction rather yes they
don't want to feel for so that's where
you're like I couldn't get to every
faction if I got me I got all three is a
hell of a grind yeah but I got them
you're gonna miss you're gonna miss out
on SunShot by the way I'm sorry I know
that was actually almost more solid than
graviton yeah easy like graviton on
console solid crazy because there's not
as much a missus on PC but SunShot oh I
know I know
I regret actually listen I live with my
decision I love my new walk the Ottomans
actually do you actually give to care
about business at all rocking careless
and and the Perkis that trash like trust
me like I really don't even use that I
literally just did it for the shaders
the armor and the new the new stuff
associated like the ship the ghosts and
all that but yeah I what my heart over
my I know I know it was not the smartest
decision but I love new monkey so much
in v2 that I just felt long that I would
miss out on that exclusive armor you
know I'm saying and I got like free
festivity I was kind of matter didn't
get to finish in my new monarchy said
yeah man I'm such a fashion guy freshman
keep it loyal for that one but shout out
the dizzy cuz he gave me so much crazy
new Monica guy you know he's so much
crap for betraying them for the first
half at dinner I said dude that's that's
it that's graviton that's the matter
like I am NOT missing that out plus what
sealed the deal as I almost didn't do it
but a funny thing did you say the eye of
another world ornament yeah with the
black space thing so and you like hey I
got the full
çetin I think I put a picture up and
you're like damn it that actually looks
pretty good
I had to have yeah that orbits tougher
for a change it was just like it wasn't
the brush stroke actually liked like the
accent of the little bit of kind of a
lime olive green axe and why it was done
it was done well bow was good I miss new
monarchies but honestly this one was
almost so busy I don't know if I'd ever
wear this one like I know I don't like
to new there's too much going on to my
previous season was so this one is like
I wanted to complete it but yeah I did
finish future war cult though we checked
that wasn't bad but just it's great very
space clean like not much going on yeah
absolutely yeah they're they're out so
they're out this is the difference
trials is out for all of season 4 right
this is on hiatus at the beginning of
season 4 right you do figure things out
and find a place to put it in mm-hmm if
they do put it in partway through season
4 right
they can't limit stuff on season 4 or
it's gonna be like a test run without
you know catalyst or whatever so right I
don't want to see but the biggest thing
you were asking about we got all this
total long off tangent the event
progression you're asking about yeah
they have to make it to where loss
verdict loss vertical loss sectors
mm-hmm not the only like efficient way
to do it yes your activities if you're
gonna go do strikes now that are all
just strikes in general that ought to be
like 15 20 tokens like know if you're
gonna make it a thousand tokens don't
make it so awful I mean yeah that's
obnoxious that was obnoxious let's call
it what it is yeah so I mean the night
like the nightfall should probably be a
few more than strikes or like five or
ten more if it's gonna be somewhat
harder lost actors can be a thing find a
way to use renown in a more variety sake
find a way where you can turn it on or
turn it off so those are the different
pieces because people would do
escalation protocol have their like be
pledged for the week and can't turn it
off and then they would do the public
event in escalation
protocol have to kill themselves like
five times yeah get back in the mix I
agree though that was a point where like
escalation protocol during faction early
weeks wasn't even like a really viable
like those are the things you need
control over like if I'm wearing the
full set or if I you know hit something
on my faction early flag what something
to say turn it on turn off I don't care
but someone like that to control it and
on top of like with raids giving you
like seven tokens for a boss or some
garbage like no that was that was
horrible oh so bad mmm crystal matches
if you win it was five if you lose it
was two uh you need to multiply that a
lot bigger like yeah you got it
sorry I mean it was just one of those
like getting to level 50 was a grind and
a half and if you want to get there put
something out there like an exotic ship
yeah put the catalyst in like also for
the armor which they finally fix thank
God my first who grinds were without the
armor for most of it yeah when you
couldn't behind a gear and they would
joke like mid-30s for both my first two
for dead orbit in future war cult mid
30s when I finally got the full set Wow
two-thirds all the way through before I
actually got to take advantage of the
public event for for yeah new monarchy
it wasn't so bad because half the time
would be like oh if I don't get it also
go get the fork because right yeah you
get the four stack wherever every now
yeah I mean I will say this I did like
the idea of us having to wear the armor
I did like that I mean I don't know just
I felt like well like with Soulstice no
I'm at night like faction rally like
what the whole idea they made you get
where the set because I felt it kind of
promoted like a little you know
nationalistic pride in the tower like
I'm down with this you don't say like I
like that part and I liked a little part
where they had that the thing when you
had a four stack or whatever when you're
back with close with the faction you
know I'm saying on your back remember oh
yeah yeah yeah no I actually really
liked that that was yeah so I like it
likes certain aspects that were there
they just got a you know do certain
things and then you know with that
limited you know participation for each
instance you know and you missing out on
that catalyst I liked that last
part of this paragraph which is
basically saying those who were unable
to acquire it you know from you know
past action wise they're working on a
new way for you to earn it so like
because my things damn I'm just never
gonna get the SunShot catalyst alright
what happens to me that is it just like
you're there like that's it so I'll just
probably have to throw it in somewhere
maybe give you a chance to earn it maybe
buy it who knows not by a bit like token
wise or something you just don't put it
in strikes oh man
I'm gonna know some people are starting
to get them from strikes now and I'm
seeing them drop but it's still like
it's a long grind for some of those
strike things they're they're an oddly
long ride ever verse actually you know
which everybody always worried about the
slippery slope with ever verse mmm-hmm
but you know what for one they never
crossed the line and two there's one
thing in here that again you can't buy
perks and I'll show you where that's at
but I'm digging this and I also it kind
of just it's just a cool picture anyway
so ever verse goals and philosophies you
want to provide players with more data I
mean she loves data so they're sharing
some of it they want to share bright in
grammar reward probabilities on
bungie.net provide players their
purchase history they don't to give
players more choices to earn words they
want full season of primitive prismatic
matrix which was I mean there was a test
things I mean that's understandable but
the free weekly prismatic facet which is
cool mmm-hmm more bright dust earned
from bounties I like the fact that you
can't actually go choose to specifically
earn bright dust this is good nice it's
not just a random drop that you
sometimes Akili or break stuff down for
come all allow players to earn new ways
to customize their Guardians ghost
projections which is above so you have
this whole Jade rabbit picture above
your ghost which is kind of cool mm-hmm
legendary weapon skins interesting no
how do you just know I'm in my head
I'm racking my brain skin versus shader
yeah we already do shaders and those
days of skins and every other game
I'm very curious about Disney that's I'm
glad you mentioned it cuz out what I
read this I was like yeah you can slap a
shader now on basically every weapon but
what swords in new exotic ornaments and
emotes so I mean that's just it's ways
to have fun in look cool and that's what
I think Cosmetics should always be I
mean that's what anything you buy should
always be that I like I mean I've always
liked it we've had this discussion many
times or I never felt you know once they
make the necessary changes that it
really encroached on anything it doesn't
give you any advantage you know I mean
it's just cosmetic stuff and I am gladly
okay
for people paying for cosmetics or any
modes that that to me is not breaking
the game I never I always felt like you
felt was always an over-exaggeration a
lot of times especially when the the
facet came out because it was process of
elimination and you ended up getting the
stuff you want you know based on you
know the orangie of the thing so you
know I was fine with that I'm cool cool
with that
yeah I was like so far they've done fine
I have no objections and I think the
prismatic thing was even better
so Everest bounties are a new thing that
are coming hm-hm basically a similar way
other bounties work they're ones that
you can that will reward brightness this
alone is great just a way to
specifically choose to go earn bright
dust yes you couldn't do that before
yeah if you have some shaders you wanna
break down or a ship or whatever one of
their stuff you want to work on every
week this is another thing to do yes all
of what we want we want things to do in
the game you have content use it yes
each bright in Graham and grants one
bounty note so as you level up you'll
get a bounty note yes house we're gonna
be playing a lot you'll probably have a
few absolutely fresh weekly players can
acquire as many ever verse bounties as
they have notes so if you saved up a lot
you can actually go have a bunch you can
have a1 a2 and a3 the notes can be
exchanged for three different tiers see
all the bounty note that rewards 22 to
reward 70 tier 3 rewards 150 which is
that amount and you can carry one of
each type at a time so technically if
you
working on all three at the same time
you could get to 40 bright dust just by
doing your bellies
oh yeah not bad nobody shoutout Lord's
Midnight Rider and some new faces uh see
if I'm pronouncing it right this sack he
two three four and of course our regular
that natural Chris Cobra elite that's my
guy
so good to see you guys in chat much
appreciate it mm-hm and kernels out
there as well and then neck so gaming
soy not even sure you got a tough one
asking you to get your salute to you
guys much appreciate you coming out
without success yeah
always thank you guys for tuning in this
is just us rambling so what if what I'm
bounties will expire seven days after
acquisition big key is if you if you
pick them up you're probably gonna want
to work on them and you most likely will
be but just know they are at least a
week now unlimited so that's probably
fair I think I mean to perfect a stack
yep mmm-hmm prismatic matrix will return
in season four which is good they said
that they were taking away doing a
couple things the nice thing is they
said the prismatic facet will be
obtained from the Tier one Everest
bounty it only cost you glimmer to buy
it
so that's cool easy and that's when you
should just literally pick that up like
every day yeah 250 glimmer come on we
ain't got to just have it all the time
seriously I want something to spend it
on which is good I'll take something to
spend my glimmer on um if it can
actually give me stuff in that store as
long as yes as long as everything always
stays is kind of an option as bright
dust and that Silver's not too uh too
tangled in there but outside of that
using your iron banner emblem yes
continue with the theme of giving
players more control over the brightness
balance brightness gained from
dismantling ever verse items will be at
a fixed rate so it's just standard which
is I mean it should be whatever is
standard you have collections the
neveress items this is just basic stuff
saying your to armor the biggest thing
and this is why I wanted to bring this
up specifically okay
so every sytems will be treated from
collections just like anything else
an exception is the year - ever verse
armour mmm which like all other armour
with random girls cannot be reacquired
from the collection stands and with
random roles and it be continually
pulled out for the specific random
rolled right ways in which players
acquire and interact with emotes and
armor have not changed all other items
can be retrieved for brightest basically
what they're saying is anything with
random roles you can't pay for it which
is exactly what I wanted to hear right I
got a question though and I actually
sent this tweet out last night to deej
damage and Cosmo I have a dilemma it may
be my own fault for doing this so stupid
because I was desperate for masterworks
to upgrade something I had master work
my dawning set helmet thinking I would
be able to get that back it was just one
of those things I had got a great gun I
think was banana man something I got
forgot the master work this and I was
like damn I don't got no sure that I was
going to before and I'm like oh look
what has nice to work on we did it yeah
and it was like hey anything from this
point on or whatever you're safe so but
is the dawning armor considered random
world you can still go get your dong
murmur where cuz is it brought of some
type of ever verse package no I'm sorry
darling no I wasn't thinking I was
thinking solstice yeah I'm dawning
remember the dawning and they had to
ship all that stuff you kinda had to pay
for no it's kind of like a pay still you
when did you just do this mandala
recently Rhys like recently way yeah
just be able to go get it it should just
be part of collection I've got to assume
hopefully they answered me back yeah cuz
I would think so - that's why I did I
was like yeah they said armor you know
from this point on you should be fine
but they made you scared me with this
statement the exception is year to ever
I looked up what you two ever verse
armor was it wasn't the dawning
so again I just got guys I said
hopefully like I said one of the three
will get back to me if not I'll hit up
hammer it and then CC him on it and see
if they can get me an answer because
they right here ever verse items will be
retrieved from collections interface
just like all other items I think as
long as it came from ever verse from the
dawning you should be able to get it
from your collections when they come out
okay I'm hoping so good
I'm Alba so - yeah yeah mmhmm right in
Graham updates oh no yes more without
not to interrupt you the case moving to
chat oh that's a survey oh no doubt
continue kitty bright in Graham updates
legendary weapon ornaments have been
added to bright engrams so that's kind
of cool mmm-hmm legendary weapon
ornaments because those didn't exist
before another ornament skins I'm still
waiting for all the distinction between
all this stuff but we'll just have to
see they're unlocked account wide that's
how it always should be thank goodness
yeah projections just like the little
Jade you know think of Jade rabbit thing
above that's pretty cool mmm-hmm
you're gonna see those basically you
bring it up in navigation mode so not
that often but just way for you to
personalize it which is fine yeah weapon
armor not mods will no longer drop from
Brighton grams which is actually good
because just the fact that you could
excuse me suspend for mods technically
you could buy mods which really don't do
squat right now but in general it's just
one of those things you can't pay for
which I like literally pulling anything
that functions in the game out of there
yeah that's closet of positive moves
mm-hm so with the addition of random
perk rolls we have made some changes to
help perks are applied to every summer I
think this is actually I'm going to be
talking about the entire verse armor
acquired from bright acquired from
bright engrams will have random perks
win reward it won't ever verse armor
acquired from sources like prismatic
matrix or the bright dust or confront
will have fixed things he's the only
year occasional drop by leveling up
meaning you have to play will have the
raiment perk roles you can't pay for
random perk role sets that's what I was
trying to get back to and I was just a
little early on it but that's like he is
like you can't pay to try and get that
perfect role on a piece of armor because
armor is gonna be one of those things
with the random perks that's cool
matter now and if you could just spend a
hundred bucks and have some good rolls
in there then you kind of took out some
of the crimes so that I wanted to make
sure was clear and I read that like
three times you know that and again for
people who don't know and don't play
this microtransactions up and you can
pay the way you cannot you know I'm
saying like that that's the thing and
people have to this is all cosmetic
stuff and like I said you can't do
anything to try to finesse the system so
to speak you know then like they they
have these thoughts in mind already with
these things coming from everywhere so
these are changes that I'm glad are
clarified so we don't have this you know
see the the destiny hate force come out
with the pigfoot pitchforks is talking
about pay2win and others are the
solution is because that is not true
yep and they just said just like before
your now I'm gonna get bright engrams as
you level up they're done at cap level
cap so you're gonna have to reach level
50 story playing and all that type of
stuff and that's probably our biggest
level jump you think yeah this is big
this is big man I was surprised he jump
was that large I was gonna say it's 30
to 50 like just the fact of it takes a
decent amount of playing I kind of I
wonder how long it's gonna take just to
hit 50 I mean I know that max power
level is gonna come to what just level
50 in and of itself normally I mean what
was taken King he took me back damn I
can't remember but I was already 32 33
34 with House of wolves 34 is max was it
40 yeah it may have been in maybe but I
don't remember it being a slaw but this
feels like time investment commitment
you know 50 and then you start worrying
about you know light levels and stuff
like that afterwards they are requiring
some dedication to this expansion this
is definitely a lot of content but make
no mistake this is not a small you know
kind of a expansion like they're going
all out with that so you know me I don't
have that much problem that no so that's
pretty much everything that's changed in
between
forever verse and economy and stuff like
that we've got a little dabble on
crucible
uh your favorite your absolute favorite
activity they've added Crucible - only
you so I think when they announced this
thing they should have set expectations
a little quicker no it was mostly the
fact that I'm I wasn't the only one that
did it as people heard crucible labs
they're like oh you can test
time-to-kill and all that stuff and then
they had to shoot that in the foot and
they're like no we can't test
time-to-kill in there because it messes
with the sandbox for the whole came
we're like okay would have been good to
know that upfront
yes right so now they're taking their
first mode that they came up with before
showdown I didn't even get to play
lockdown and actually sounded kind of
cool because it was zone control for the
bringing back showdown 90 second rounds
score limit of ten revives are enabled
which is actually kind of cool worried
about me teammate pulls the point back
from their opponents so it's a way for
them to mix it up
I mean crucible abs for me is either
here nor there it's just kind of like
it's a way to dabble in something
different in crucible abs I tried
showdown for about three rounds and it
was like all right yeah the crowd of
Crisco he said he have a death cupola
don't feel bad I haven't tested either
the last one the first one was so long
ago I barely played it so it's we go
into the crucible tablets in the upper
right I just don't know when it's active
they say yeah I've never even seen it
basically the base thing is just watched
Twitter here's the thing I can say is
follow them on Twitter yeah oh shut out
- Lord zero by the way talking about
Monster Hunter coming out on PC yes I
know anyway we gotta get zero on a flash
point so no mm-hmm
but showdown will be kind of cool this
will be so whether you play it on the
first time this will be have some
changes it's quick rounds the 10 sec 10
score limit is actually pretty small but
revives might make that a little longer
especially a snipers coming back there's
gonna be some people picked off for a
second
but revives kind of mixing it up so
we'll see if this is something's kind of
fun I just don't know when as they said
before watch Twitter vulturing keep an
eye out we will for those you guys
working on the valores all the Valor
double Valor and triple Valor weekends
are coming let's go
starting today in about two and a half
hours double Valor weekend now triple
valor was probably a little more
fruitful but double valor whilst mayhem
as active is still probably your best
time to grind out some Valor
so that's the biggest thing I can say is
if you want to get up to legend if you
want to at least master work one of your
pieces of Soulstice armor you need to
get to legend use these for that yep
that's fun it's quick it's not to like
you know sweaty have some fun in there
this weekend doing this in conjunction
with iron banner right so you know
pretty good time to get in there have
some fun six knock it out I mean that's
how I got I'm actually working on my
second I'm very close to my second
Christine's nice I've left it I left it
at my first procedure cuz I wanted to
make sure I got the armor yes and that
was why but now it's gonna be a double
Valor week by the way
so it's today through next Friday then
it changes so it's not just the weekend
this time the first one's a week long so
that's cool
then we'll have triple Valor and then
double Valor for the last couple of
weekends so just a way to get some value
if you're trying to finish some stuff up
mm-hmm
hell yes so it's and these are things
like Call of Duty does and stuff like
that it's just incentive to come back
and place it absolutely so I like I like
an occasional like once a month thing
like when they do their monthly roadmap
for that picture hey this will be like
Oh crucibles gonna be this 2x weekend or
something like that like throw it on
there give people a heads up it's coming
that's all agreed I said not all heroes
wear capes we've got some you know
patches and things like that they
mentioned this is the one achieved the
legend rank in valor crucible you have
to max out your valor rating max out by
the way you have to have to
points and then you have to complete one
more match so if you're looking to get
that legendary solstice armor to master
worked on that one piece I forget if
it's the mark or what I did it max out
your valor leave it there complete one
match then you're good so that one's a
big one
[Music]
players weekly max of a low-ranking
before the stalled of start of solstice
of euros and have previously reset their
valor and whose legend requirement is
not already marked as complete need to
complete an additional match so I can
reset it now which is good I just wanted
to make sure I was like wow so you're
pretty safe never never quite no
objective percentages on solstice may
round up to the nearest whole digit if
they see it displays 100% but not marked
just go to you know shoot one more guy
get one more or yes mm-hmm
there are some known issues if you for
this is the biggest one for me
players on PC a report of the redux
mission statues are not interactable
I'll literally go into the tower and I
can interact with like two or three at a
time but never all of them so when I did
my solo runs they were out of order
because of that so you're not alone
also on console you may have some issues
interacting with the almighty mission
the tank doesn't actually see left or
right some Mobile's mobile devices you
might see your shirt so if you ever an
issue just go straight through
bungie.net for your shirt don't mess
with the yeah mm-hm
got some faction around lead ants off
your good old videos of the week
dado pulled up ii actually thought it
was gonna get number one cuz i saw him
have a pretty high score but apparently
somebody's cranking some stuff out yeah
they still lacking out directly rock and
jesus yes 300 thou boys is white no no
110 done i think it was very many and i
forget what this week is it's been
another exciting week Soulstice of yours
is in full swing
iron banners next week fewer than three
weeks and at the start of year two on
august 28 so their technical year to
August 28th even though four seconds in
next week but
you know yeah but where you get your
when you get your hands on the sandbox
changes so August 28 to remember your
weapons damage type be a void Ark or
solar will lock so make sure you check
the lists we'll have in the description
look on reddit bullet writing it in the
description on both of our videos all
the changes are coming so you can dabble
with your snipers you can see what moved
have some fun in that one and then
forsaken man dude I'm fairly I'm just
reading the words finally visit the
Dreaming city for yourself and just like
well you we still have to go through the
Barrens we still have to go through
Aldrin we have to get the Dreaming city
we have to explore the upside down we
haven't even seen anything about the
raid we've got the oh my god
like it just keeps going as a stabbing
we're gonna have a lot of work to do and
it's for me it's just like full-time job
right now I'm I'm just prepping myself
I'm trying to get all I got like a list
of things that I need for me personally
that I want done before forsaken so that
I am prepared because unlike I know a
lot of shout out to tasks in a couple
people but like hey you know one stuff
is gonna be use this I don't necessarily
think everything is because at the end
of the day even though random roles are
back and stuff like that you got to
remember orange Jesus still has to bless
you with these roles and being that d1 I
mean I'm saying like of course it's
gonna be stuff that's gonna eventually
outclassed and names midnight and the
banana man and you know I'm saying that
you know sort of things but like when I
see I close shotgun and all that stuff I
still have to get there's a couple of
cameras that for me like I have to get
like sleeper simulant still my baby I'm
gonna do that spires of stars prestige
I'm going to try to get that catalyst
you know I'm saying get that rocking you
know is I still have like a little
laundry list of checkbox so that this
way I am prepared across the board PvP
PvE loadout wise because in the
beginning you know you're still gonna
need good weapons to while you're going
through the Forsaken campaign and stuff
like that so you know that's what my
mind said what about you are you kind of
a little bit of a grind or you just like
a you know I'm leaving all that stuff
and just waiting for to do stuff I mean
yeah I think for you as I said like
there's some
if I definitely want to kind of do like
you know probably a tidy up the office
can a couple things just gonna give
things already figure out work schedule
it's still probably just gonna be what
it has been I don't think too much is
probably gonna change there might see if
I can switch a Wednesday for a Monday or
move a few things around but overall
like the vaults gonna come on I think
the 28 is perfect because we get the
week before to tidy up and then we have
in the game that's like okay can I
delete some stuff I see what's in the
collections I don't care about some old
garbage rocket launcher those yeah be to
no choose three or four pieces of
duplicate armor we changing I don't know
it a lot actually gonna change but just
the five hundred vaults lots I can move
stuff around shaders break down the ones
I don't get just all that stuff I can go
unique and I'm not rushed in that first
like day but I also have to kind by
hunter out to be high enough to be
functional so I have all three
characters cuz yeah it's my fifth
character because I did two on
PlayStation I may have like dabbled in
if I started probably one there but I
did two on PC and I'm like I need my
third on PC so I gotta round up my PC
someone hunter grind I still have to go
through the story one more time yeah man
I like that that's pretty much I mean
that prep mode I'm ready
shut up the Crisco bro you're lucky I
still didn't get my midnight cool I'm
working on that you know it's like
that's good yeah dude I just been orange
Jesus has not but you only can they
bless me that I really do like from that
obviously I gots into the past early and
seen it of York I cannot recommend that
shotgun I locate like it better than
perfect paradox and them it just has a
lot a lot of intrinsic perks that I feel
a lot better
but I'm yeah man it still some things to
for me to do so this is this is good man
I'm hi I'm ready we're on the cusp all
these changes for the most part sound
good just a few we just got to see how
it works you know in terms of
implementation but they don't a right
track man and like you said as we
started it's that quiet confidence like
they on the right side they looks like
this thing is gonna be back full swing
and it's great to see everybody playing
shout out to my clan
everybody's playing it's just huge this
is the most investment we've seen and to
see this from where we started
flashpoint cuz I go back to those first
episodes man I go back to our tone like
damn what's gonna happen with this game
it was funeral talk so it's good to see
you know the resurrection so to speak
let's see if they continue through yep
yeah so pumped hype only a couple more
weeks enjoy them guys cuz we gonna be a
hardcore after a little bit oh so much
to look forward to like I can reread I
could reread this table like three times
I'm like I'll catch something new every
time yep I was good as a big last day
absolutely
well guys I think that's probably a
decent place to wrap it up dreaming city
looks amazing so many changes are coming
you got your week of prep on the 28th
yeah follow us like stay tuned
get your time in the game get ready for
everything that's coming we gonna be
busy there's gonna be at all just too
much to do which is something we all
have missed so long yeah we have a
mystery guest approaching on the angle
podcast obviously every Sunday is the
Lord's Day 1 p.m. Eastern on the inner
circle Network that's where we go live
for a week before we go archive the
episode here on the IOP channel and stay
tuned i LP channel obviously flashpoint
me we doubled it this week we gave you
two you know it was a very busy week
it's good things but it was so much to
talk about
and yeah you found me on Twitter at Lord
[ __ ] needle please follow me
if you are looking for a destiny clan on
Xbox man we've got some heavy hitters
out here we are rockin look for iron
Lords podcast on the destiny companion
app if you're looking for a clan we just
asked it to be active you'd be courteous
we were very helpful we really try to
help everybody out
you know shout out to tea for tactical
King David a lot of people man we really
like we're running these raids like
clockwork we're doing escalation
protocols you know long G if you have a
request to something you need whatever
it means just put it in the chat you
the Destiny to companion app and we
really help guys out as much as probably
got guardians from different time zones
it whatever you need to just put out
there join a party be respectful and we
will help so I'm very proud of the clan
right now we're really growing and yeah
man that that's all I got so like I said
just make tune in this Sunday we got a
lot of the topics to talk about and
again thanks for showing up today I like
some new faces in the chat it's always
good to see please supported bounces
guys out here putting great content you
know I mean love what he's doing and
yeah man that's what I got Lord
Pontius what do you got man well it's
always hard to follow you know but yeah
I got my new logo starting to pop up I'm
working on the final couple of guys up
we I got it in the little circle one but
working on a couple banners those are
the final pieces though kinda get
strapped up everywhere but all in all
that's pretty much done we've got I'm
gonna try and potentially do one or two
videos just breaking all this stuff down
and just a little succinct action if you
need to check like certain options maybe
some guns to check out from the list on
reddit but definitely check the
description for that reddit article it's
got a list of basically every weapon
what damage type it's going to they list
the ones that are going to kinetic so
outside of those lock him in mm-hmm
I mean by the police haven't moved their
wise yeah YouTube twitch Twitter all of
the places I might dabble in Monster
Hunter which is terrifying
like I don't want to see it just cuz my
brother bought it for me so shout out to
him for a little birthday I just want to
see what it's all about so I might do a
little bit with that if I do might see a
few videos on that as well
cuz we gonna see him in fancy and pretty
PC style other than that yeah I'm
sitting there talking occasionally with
Cognito about PC build in parts and
trying to get him up out of a laptop
phase so let him fool you
he knows this is the ultimate set up
plan to get me over there scarred right
now it comes with destiny
just have to get that forsaken expansion
you locked oh no that's good stuff it's
a good time up here on the UH you know
yesterday about it a richer color it uh
it uh I felt what you speak up
I see don't forget us little guys but I
cuz I'll be having a good PC bill from
Iceland eat Bacchus no yours is just so
you can do all the stuff that you want
to do because I know for editing and
stuff like that it's a little different
so he's been he's been putting in some
work with what he's God so it's time for
him to join the a just he's probably
gonna be really happy once he gets it so
yeah well yeah we having some fun guys
out there stay tuned follow us on
Twitter you guys are known to go live
watch the new videos come up subscribe
to the channels both iron Lords podcast
and Yvonne tes YouTube channel both of
those follow us there we'll keep this
stuff coming to you guys so thank you as
always for tuning in I know it's a long
outro but we just like to share a
support with you guys so thank you thank
you for everything all you do just by
being here with us makes it great so we
will see you guys later have yourselves
a good one and talk to you soon peace